nine-one-one what are you reporting oh
there's someone or some kind of creature
prancing around out here okay is it a
person an animal or I can't tell it
looks like a woman but she's about six
feet tall being man ham I'm sorry your
call to report a tall woman with man ham
well she's cover the butterflies and
challenge I'll win Oh talk about a
member out of this wood do not desire to
go thou shalt remain here whether thou
wilt right now and I the purge that
mortal grossness so that thou shalt like
an airy spirit go
[Music]
Hale mortals I come to thee from my
fairy Grove to bring the tidings of
great woe Western culture is being
destroyed by [ __ ] and by gender-bending
intoxication and sodomy
you know things that have never happened
in Europe
[Music]
there's a lot of people talking lately
about the West and Western culture and
Western civilization but what are those
words even mean I guess the mature and
responsible thing to do would be a
simple educational video to edify the
public Fox ow people demand blood and
I'm thirsty for blood and by blood
I mean dick and by dick I mean corndogs
and by corndogs I mean 16 of them over
the course of an evening and by evening
I mean morning and by morning I mean
between 8 o'clock and 8:15 and by
corndogs who's up first
well angry white guy YouTube is usually
talking about Western culture and it's
been awhile since I've done a video
response so let's see what's going on in
that part of the internet Magog is here
baby doll
that is a mad
Wow I've never done a video response to
such a powerful wizard the second and
third clues are else's magical powers
and the song let it go
both of these clues have to do with
coming up a magic power is the conflict
of the plot and her letting it go
it's just her realizing her true
potential
and her ability to conquer and rule her
kingdom she will destroy her enemies and
raise their castles to the ground some
let it goes basically [ __ ] this [ __ ] I'm
conquering everyone so just to be clear
this is this is a grown man who has
dressed himself in the garb of a
sorcerer to shout about a YouTube
channel for preschoolers it almost feels
like punching down at this point at
least the golden one was mask for mask
who can I punch out that well I don't
like talking about punching it makes me
feel like one of those people who talks
about punching turfs I would never a
bunch of turf
my hands are too feminine and my fingers
are tired
someone massage them who can I claw up
at the fundamental assumptions of
Western civilization are valid how about
that
dad stop get out of my life in my video
about Jordan Peterson I talked about how
he posits a struggle between the West
and postmodern neo Marxism I argued that
homo Nomo is a label that includes a
bunch of incompatible ideas none of
which are in any sense non-western
unless of course you equate the West
with white people and Marxism with the
Jews which surely no one involved in
this conversation is doing a right
he wasn't a fan of the backseat in this
video I want to look a little bit closer
at the whole concept of the West and the
people who claim to defend it
Wow dad a nice sword
god damn it we're gonna need to aim even
higher ladies gentlemen and beyond I
give you the President of the United
States of America
big dick special big boy Donald Trump
just as Poland could not be broken I
declare today for the world to hear that
the West will never ever be broken our
values will prevail our people will
thrive and our civilization will triumph
[Applause]
[Music]
so we've got the most powerful [ __ ] boy
on the planet prattling on about the
battle for the survival of Western
civilization so I suppose we should
probably figure out what that's supposed
to mean which is too bad because that's
gonna require a lot of thinking and I
don't feel like thinking because my
brain is tired
someone massaged it and soon
mechanically dispirited after a dreary
day with the prospect of a depressing
morrow I raised to my lips a spoonful of
the tea and which I soaked a morsel of
the corndog no sooner had the warm
liquid mixed with the dog touched my
palate and a shudder ran through me and
I stopped intent upon the extraordinary
thing that was happening to me
an exquisite pleasure had invaded my
senses something isolated detached with
no suggestion of its origin and at once
the vicissitudes of life had become
indifferent to me as disasters innocuous
its brevity illusory this new sensation
having had on me the effect which a love
has a post pre ambulatory banter whether
you're in fatty YouTube or poem oh no mo
akadama no it's comments take for
granted that there is a historically
continuous clearly defined thing called
Western civilization that starts in
ancient Athens and flourishes in our own
era of enlightened philosopher kings but
this is really just a story constructed
retrospectively by modern people for
particular purposes it's like an orange
in meth in an article titled there is no
such thing as Western civilization the
philosopher Kwame Anthony Appiah points
out that for the ancient Greek historian
Herodotus there was no such thing as the
West the world was divided into three
continents he called Europe Asia and
Libya Herodotus had no notion that these
three continents correspond to different
types of people and he never referred to
any group of people
the Europeans in fact he was much more
familiar with Egypt in Persia in which
he traveled than with the far away and
foreign people of northern Europe so the
idea of the West has to be more recent
than that really there is no one idea of
the West which is an umbrella term that
includes a lot of discontinuous cultures
and contradictory ideas according to me
there are six different concepts often
invoked under the heading of the West
let's talk about them now concept one
christened demand judeo-christian values
in the year 732 a soldier named Charles
Martel led Frankish forces to victory at
the Battle of Tor against the Islamic
forces that had advanced from Spain into
what is now France effectively halting
the spread of the Umayyad Caliphate into
Western Europe according to a paya the
first recorded use of the Latin term
Europe MCs for Europeans dates from 754
and describes the victors of the Battle
of Tora distinguishing Christians from
Muslims in the late Middle Ages the
concept of chrysanthemum appeared and
was used to distinguish the Christian
world from the Islamic world and from
paganism this idea of Christendom is
arguably the earliest precursor to the
modern concept of the West notice that
the term itself posits and us versus
them dichotomy where Christians or the
US and Muslims or the sound the
Christian inheritance is still invoked
today by defenders of the West like lil
Benny and professor studied the blade
often under the heading of
judeo-christian a term usually used to
falsely imply that contemporary moral
norms derived from such a generic
parochial and incomplete document as the
Ten Commandments as if every major
civilization didn't have laws against
murder as if the prohibition of graven
images has any contemporary influence
whatsoever as if it isn't an
embarrassment that there are four laws
protecting snowflake Yahweh's easily
triggered ego and non condemning slavery
and rape and what if I like it when my
neighbor covets Maya Bible jokes the
other main use of judeo-christian values
is as a bludgeon against single parents
and the queers speaking of which what
exactly are the family values we inherit
from
and um two kids and a dog just like the
Bible says
well no polygon II is specifically
acknowledged in the Old Testament and
not forbidden in either Testament even
in the beginning Eve couldn't keep her
hands away from strange serpents and who
can blame her and Joseph was a massive
[ __ ] who raised another man's child but
it's cool he was into that in the Middle
Ages the Catholic Church gradually
enforced the one man and one woman view
of marriage
although informally pagan lands this
idea was slow to take hold Charles
Martel's grandson Charlemagne had 18
kids by at least 10 wives and concubines
because he was a proud son of the North
100% natty and Alpha's [ __ ] I'm sorry I
I just can't stop the golden one his
soul and mine are intermingled probably
because we both played twelve hundred
hours of Age of Empires in 1999 and then
something went terribly wrong [ __ ]
9/11 used to be such an innocent
decision choosing to play as the Franks
or the Saracens then it became this huge
civilizational struggle and that's why
this guy is a fascist and I grew up to
be a woman thanks a lot Osama being
transgender is so weird
like you have these childhood memories
that are just totally discordant with
your adult gender identity like how do
you even deal with that well here's how
you bond with straight guys over your
shared age of empires nostalgia and then
you [ __ ] them I'm not like
[Music]
concept to enlightenment values so in
1517 an annoying social justice warrior
named Martin Luther nails his list of
whiney complaints to the door of the
church and Vidhan burg that kicks off a
century or so of brutal violence between
Catholics and Protestants that
eventually chills out but then the 18th
century rolls around and shit's just
[ __ ] crazy
there are various fops and Gandhi's
macaronis getting wired out of their
heads at coffee houses and babbling
about enlightenment like the beatnik
trash they are then 300 years later a
bunch of drink sought and Fedora tippers
appointed themselves intellectual
descendants of Voltaire before sinking
into sweeping sexual harassment
allegations under the rug
and making fifty five consecutive
YouTube videos about how Anita
sarkeesian is destroying video games
that's not what they were discussing at
the Parisian salon this is all very
embarrassing but still some of these
enlightenment values science Liberty
skepticism about dogma
these are basically good ideas and
they're part of the amalgamation we call
the West but it's important to keep in
mind that these ideas are not
judeo-christian in fact they're
specifically opposed to that way of
thinking so the some of what we now
think of as the West actually contains
major contradictions because the history
of the West is a history of change and
revolution so what a new movement comes
a long lake for instance a bunch of
buzzkill sad sacks pointing out that
actually our society is still pretty
terrible to women people of color and
gender and sexual minorities it might
not be the smartest thing to just
dismiss it as some kind of sinister
postmodern new Marxist cockle tree it
could be the next reformation in a
history March by a series of
informations if there are any historians
watching this please call it the SJW
reformation think about the Protestant
Reformation
at the time that probably seemed like a
civilizational threat at the Holy Roman
Empire and they kinda was but in
retrospect we see the Reformation as
just as important a moment in Western
culture as the medieval period that
preceded it
but today's counter-reformation made up
of people like orangie smalls and dr.
clean your room insist on pretending the
current reformation is some kind of
alien threat and as for the counter
counter Reformation
well that's what you pay a trashy Tran
to do concept three Western culture the
idea of the West has its roots in the
medieval schism between the Western
Roman Catholic Church and the Eastern
Orthodox Church but in its contemporary
sense the idea of Western culture didn't
really exist until the imperialist era
of the late 19th and early 20th
centuries when it was popularized in
part by Oswald Spengler is 1918 book the
decline of the West an important
influence on Nazi ideology as long as
people have been talking about Western
culture they've been worried about its
alleged decline in degeneration as I've
discussed in several earlier videos
which I encourage you not to watch but
the idea of Western culture was
influential well beyond the third right
at the height of European imperialism
the idea of a superior high culture of
the West was a convenient excuse to
plunder and exploit the mysterious
Orient and even though we've swept the
matter overtly supremacist rhetoric
under the rug
the idea of Western culture is still a
foundational concept in our schools and
universities where you have to take
courses like history of Western
civilization or Western literature but
you didn't actually do any of the
readings for because you're too busy
crouching in the bushes outside the
dean's office vomiting up a couple pints
of Malibu the consequence of this
Western culture education is that we now
all have this sense that we belong to a
continuous civilization whose crowning
achievements are the ten commandments
jesus-fuckin'-christ athenian pederasts
cathedrals Mozart human rights science
and iPhones but the reality is this is
an essentialist conglomeration of a
history that's much more nonlinear
we often think we in the West claim to
be the inheritors of the ancient
traditions of Aristotle and Abraham but
the Islamic world is entitled to just
the same claim st. Thomas Aquinas one of
the most powerful Catholic sorcerers is
largely responsible for introducing
Aristotle to Christian universities but
he never would have encountered
Aristotle in the first place
had not ancient Greek philosophy been
translated and commentated by Islamic
scholars like even rushed so the origins
of Western culture aren't really unique
to us at all and the stuff that is
unique is just a mess of contradictions
on the one hand you have judeo-christian
values and on the other hand you have
degenerates like William Shakespeare who
wrote plays for men to dress up as fairy
Queens and make out with each other
which for the record is disgusting and I
condemn it and I'll have no part in it
cuz if you didn't know
and Shakespeare times boys and drag
played female parts I wish I had female
parts working on it
concept for the free world from 1941 to
1945 Franklin Roosevelt's vice-president
was Henry Wallace an agricultural
scientist from Iowa whom Democratic
Party officials despised for being what
we'd now call a Democratic Socialist
while this later ran for president in
1948 as a third party candidate on a
platform of universal health care
anti segregation in opposition to the
Cold War during the campaign Wallace was
widely mocked in the press for his
spiritualism his refusal to disavow the
communist party's endorsement and what
Time magazine called
his assault on the south that is his
quote ostentatious ride through cities
and towns with his negro secretary
beside him for which he was pelted with
tomatoes and eggs the poor naive Wallace
commented there is something so well
lovely about hate when you see it
distorting the human phase well get used
to it buddy
this is America am i lecturing someone
from 1940 about how bigoted this country
is this is fine Wallace received only
2.4 percent of the popular vote in the
1948 election and he's now best
remembered for his 1942 speech titled
the century of the common man in which
he contrasts in what he called the slave
world of fashion
with the free world what he described as
an incomplete and ongoing international
People's Revolution no Nazi comfort
revolution will stop
the common man will swap the Hitler
Stooges out into the open in the United
States in Latin America and in India he
will destroy their influence no levels
no Mussolini's will be tolerated in a
free world Wallace had an especially
left-wing take on it but it was common
during World War two when the phrase the
free world first entered common parlance
to include all the countries opposing
the Axis powers including the dirty Reds
after the war the phrase the free world
remained common in American politics but
the meaning shifted instead of referring
to the international alliance against
fascism they referred to the capitalist
West as opposed to the communist East
the idea of the free capitalist West is
still an important ingredient in this
jumbled concept we call Western
civilization
so when lobster dad says is a struggle
between Marxism and the West it seems at
first like he's just stuck in the 1980s
or something
doesn't he know there's no more Eastern
Bloc dad what year do you think it is
are you at war in your head with the
goddamn brewskies they're on your side
now remember the truth is he's just
using the term neo Marxism to invoke Red
Scare sentiment in opposition to the SJW
Reformation but the point I'm trying to
make is that the West is a concept or
rather several contradictory concepts
that are always posited in particular
political circumstances as one side of
an us-versus-them opposition whether
it's the Christian West versus the
infidels the Enlightenment West versus
Islam the cultured West versus the
colonized savages the capitalist West
versus the communist East where the
white European West versus the Jewish
cultural Marxist plot to [ __ ] the sons
of the north by besmirching the purity
of their fair maidens in
in their countries with a barbarous
Board of third-world migrants I guess I
have to say something about that concept
five blood and soil if you ask leading
Nazi social-media influencer Richard
Spencer what he thinks the West is he'll
tell you that it's a cultural Geographic
and genetic inheritance bequeathed to
European people by their fair-skinned
ancestors to Spencer the idea that a
person of Asian or African descent could
be part of the West is ridiculous
because for Spencer to be Western is to
be white now the thing about that is as
an analysis of the common usage of the
term the West it's not even wrong
consider Latin America where the main
languages spoken are Spanish Portuguese
and French where the majority of
religion is room and Catholicism why is
this region generally not regarded as
part of the west by our immigrants from
this region demonized as alien intruders
well because it's people have too much
melanin to join the club or to be more
accurate the flexible and historically
variant concepts of whiteness and the
West have been constructed so as to
exclude them and I've already spent half
my youtube career on delirious gay
screeching about Nazis so I don't want
to do more of that now but suffice to
say the association between whiteness
and the West is always lurking beneath
the surface and when whiteness rears its
head proudly the result is the ugliest
crimes our civilization is capable of as
I'm making this video the machinery of
the middle stages of those crimes is up
and running yet again thanks to a
refugee crisis in Europe and a racist
demagogue in the United States and once
more both continents are dotted with
barbed wire refugee cádiz and internment
camps full of children torn from parents
concept six the evil West the West in
many ways is an inherently supremacist
concept it's thought to be more
civilized more holy and more cultured
than the non West but there are some
ridiculous college professors who adopt
this story wholesale but flip it on its
head according to them the West is not
uniquely civilized but uniquely
uncivilized cruel imperialistic racist
and genocidal but this just perpetuates
the same essentializing error Europe
aren't inherently more evil anymore than
they're inherently more civilized
if capitalist imperialism had burst out
of Africa 400 years ago the result would
have been just as brutal so instead of
vilifying the West I think we should get
rid of the concept altogether adopt a
more cosmopolitan understanding of
ourselves and acknowledge that the world
is too complicated to reduce to simple
us and them binaries which is not to say
that we have to get rid of Aristotle in
classical music and the Cheesecake
Factory we can still keep all that [ __ ]
while eliminating the propaganda and
injustice that surrounds it coda my mind
is a predator that preys upon itself
what if traps are gay what if no one can
ever love you
what if happiness is impossible what if
everyone who complements me is lying
they can laugh at me leader when I
delusionally feel good if whatever if
when you die you stay conscious and then
you just saw what if I'm standing in an
awkward way and it looks weird
what if Blanche shard is right what are
these horrible goddamn noises coming out
of my mouth sometimes you just need a
break from your own brain and music is
really great for that I've always liked
classical music when I listen to Mozart
or Mendelssohn or even an amateur like
sati my mind has lifted to a higher
plateau and I don't care what
civilization
came from or whether he was a bigot or a
sexist and I don't want to know because
I need this I need this feeling that
makes me just want to take a big inside
of my balls
are not gonna fit to it once
so okay fine he is the head of an ass
but there's certain advantages to that
that's all I'm saying
[Music]
whoa